let's speak to Leo Juliet now she's
based in New York and was a victim of
revenge porn while at school hello to
you Lea thanks for joining us can't even
begin to imagine the embarrassment the
fury all of those emotions that go
through your head can you talk us
through what happened to you sure hope a
thanks for having me when I was 14 years
old and only a sophomore in high school
a partner of mine posted four nude
photos of me on the internet on a an
anonymous sexual image website and since
I have been unable to get them taken
down he posted the pictures after
realizing that I was gay and posted them
in an attempt to humiliate and shame me
and humiliate and shame he did he kept
me quiet regarding the incident for
approximately four to five years until
last year when I finally spoke out about
what had happened to me okay why can you
not get the pictures taken done well
originally the photos were taken down
however as soon as the photos get taken
down off of one website and another
website often emerges because this
content on these websites is illegal
sexual content often of underage
individuals and so often the website
itself gets taken down and then another
one emerges so it's it's almost like
trying to play a game of cat-and-mouse
it's almost impossible to get them taken
down for good once they're out there how
then do you start to come to terms with
what's happened and how do you deal with
that in your own mind it's almost
impossible to come to terms with it
right away you're filled with a sense of
shame and dread and humiliation that
that is indescribable truly I personally
saw all of my hopes and ambitions just
vanished before my eyes because I
thought that anything that I
accomplished it would automatically be
be struck down by his attempts to
further humiliate me and ridicule me on
a national platform however what I was
able to do was realize that in taking
back my own nudity and in reclaiming my
voice I had more power over him than he
thought that he had over me so I was
able to stand up for myself and truly
that is the only way that I've been able
to overcome this incident yeah oh my
darling you shouldn't be ashamed my
goodness me it's not your fault I mean
all you were doing was you know taking
your clothes off with a mum that you
wanted to be with at that time I mean
how do you feel towards him he's the one
that should be ashamed of course and of
course I was only 14 at the time so I
was certainly at an age where I wouldn't
expect myself to understand the
difference between what could
potentially affect me forever and you
know what I should do
of course I have no I mean I'm angry at
him to a degree but I truly feel bad for
him because I'm sure that him doing that
came out of a scorn and then ill-will
towards me that he Herbert and I'm sure
that that will affect him forever
knowing that he did that to me but I've
come out on top in this situation I've
been able to amplify my voice and have
wonderful opportunities utilizing this
horrible incident for my own benefit now
as an activist and I've come out on top
so I truly have no ill-will towards him
I thank him even for helping me realize
how strong I am and helping me to be
able to amplify my voice very
magnanimous Sophie what would you say to
others who are perhaps not as strong as
you and find themselves in a similar
position there you're certainly not
alone and I know that that may seem
cliche but often times victims are
revenge poor and find themselves in
their own little corner of the world's
darkened by shame and humiliation
feeling as if that nobody else goes
through this you know unless they've
committed suicide afterwards or their
celebrity and they're able to quickly
sweep it under the rug but there's a
whole community of every gender of
victims and allies who are willing to
stand up and speak out for you I'm
certain
one of them I will always help to be a
voice for those who feel as if they
can't beat their own you can always
contact me and talk to me and you were
truly truly never alone in your
experience what impact does it have on
your family my family of course was
disappointed when they heard that this
had happened but they were they stood up
for me and they were very proud of me
and my ambitions to be an activist for a
revenge porn I I can't speak for how
they personally felt that I know that
they were they I'm sure that they wish
that that that haven't happened but
they've been nothing but supportive for
me it's great to talk to you and I love
your hair
thanks ray yeah thanks so much for
joining us we really appreciate it thank
you
it's my frog business